michael flynn's three-year legal fight
is over after president trump pardoned
him yesterday the president's first
national security adviser
admitted to lying about his contacts
with russia
presidential pardon could lead to others
in mr trump's final weeks in office
then tracy reports from the white house
where the president is spending
thanksgiving
lock her up retired lieutenant general
michael flynn campaigned long and hard
for president trump in 2016
but he lasted just 23 days as national
security advisor
fired by the president in 2017 for lying
to the fbi and vice president mike pence
about contact with the then russian
ambassador before the inauguration
flynn told the fbi he never advised the
russians against retaliating for
sanctions imposed by the outgoing obama
administration
but the fbi had taped his conversations
flynn pled guilty then later tried to
withdraw his plea
president trump has claimed it's all
part of what he calls
the russia hoax what they've done to
general flynn and to other people
is a disgrace while the president was
issuing the pardon
president-elect biden was pleading with
americans not to let down their guard
during thanksgiving
as the coronavirus surges i know the
country has grown
weary of the fight he said a vaccine is
on its way
his transition team receiving its first
briefing from the trump administration
on vaccine distribution wednesday
there's real hope tangible hope
so hang on don't let yourself surrender
to the fatigue which i understand
it is real fatigue i know we can and we
will beat this virus
america is not going to lose this war
president trump
is still not surrendering to the reality
that he lost the election
this election was rigged he was greeted
by cheers when he called into a
republican event
about supposed election fraud in
pennsylvania wednesday
to urge gop lawmakers to overturn joe
biden's more than 80
000 vote victory it's a disgrace that
this is happening to our country
we won this election by a lot we got 74
million votes
he did get nearly 74 million votes but
biden got more than 80 million
and won the electoral college by as much
as president trump beat hillary clinton
in 2016. president trump met with some
of the lawmakers from that event in
pennsylvania last night here at the
white house meanwhile a
judge in pennsylvania has issued a
temporary halt to the state
certification process
until a hearing on friday and that
decision is already being appealed
but since pennsylvania already certified
the election for joe biden earlier this
week
it's unclear what impact that order
would even have
vlad all right ben tracy at the white
house for us ben happy thanksgiving and
thank you very much